You guys want to hear something
terrifying? The prophecy of the popes.
This book in the Vatican archives
predicted every single pope from 1143
all the way to our current pope. But the
scary thing is after Pope Francis, the
last one, it just says judgment. And
according to St. Malachi's prediction,
this end time following the reign of the
112th Pope is right around the corner.
And the story goes that he fell into a
trance all that night. He would mention
these Latin phrases. Each one of these
Latin phrases would match up to the
reign of a particular pope. And in that
vision, he saw 112 popes up until the
tribulation time to the end. Pope
Francis has died. What just happened is
ramifications for the future, even for
the end times. So, what do you think? Is
this the last pope? No, because they're
already starting to vote in the next
one. They're working on it right now.
So, but what if something goes wrong?
Uh, they have plenty of people to choose
from. They have plenty of people to
choose from. You don't So, you don't
think that Francis was the last? I mean,
there's a lot of, I guess, hype and and
news and things concerning this, right?
I don't know if you've seen any of that
right now, but there's a lot of like,
oh, he was supposed to be the last one.
Yeah. I think it was like he was the
last one and after that the end of the
world was going to come or something
like that. Very interesting. Yeah. Very
interesting. I um I came across we we'll
get into the original like idea of what
spawned this, but one of the people that
um had something to say about this I
thought was strange was Nostradamus.
People are picking up on Nostradamus.
Not that he's the most credible person
that's out there, but some believe that
Nostradamus predicted the death of the
pope in 2025. And of course, his stuff
is always very vague. Mhm. So here's
here's what he wrote. He said um through
the death of a very old pontiff. Mhm. A
Roman of good age will be elected. Of
him it will be said that he weakens his
seat, but long will he sit and in
mortant activity. Okay, that's
definitely vague. It's super vague. And
they say this is relates to 2025. I
understand why they think that because
Pope Francis was elected in old age. Um,
you don't think he was at an old age?
No, he was. Yeah, he was. Yeah, he was
actually one of the older popes, at
least as trackable, you know, as we
know. So, and he dies at 88 years old.
Mhm. Pope Leo I 13th died at 93. Mhm.
And that made him the oldest pope in
modern history. Benedict the 16th, he
stepped down at 85. Mhm. So had he kept
going maybe I mean I don't know what I
don't know when Benedict died. I don't
know how old he was. Two three years ago
or so. Yeah. So he might have been the
oldest pope in modern history. Maybe if
he'd have kept going. Um Pope John Paul
II, you know, the very well-known
um pope. He was elected at 58 and died
at 85. Wow. He was on for a while. He
was on Yeah, he was in for a while. And
then you have like Clement who was
elected at 51 and Benedict the 9th, he
was the youngest elected at about 20.
Mhm. So when they're talking about age
of popes, yeah, it it seems like Francis
is older, you know, as far as most of
them go. But this is so vague like I
think you could pin this on, you know, a
number of right of popes. Although he's
saying and at least the news source I
was looking at was saying this was for
2025. though. Coincidence? Mhm. Mhm.
Probably. He also hinted at details of
the successor to Francis writing, "A
young man of dark skin with the help of
the great king will deliver the the
purse to another of red color."
What? Why the red? No idea what that
means. I mean, dark skin maybe African
because I know they're looking there are
a lot of cardinals that have been voted
in by Francis who are from Africa. So
they're looking at likely the next pope
being from Africa, Asia, or or Latin
America. But the red color, the only way
we refer to people having red skin,
which is almost a derogatory way of
talking about it is Native Americans. So
yeah. So I don't know. I don't know if
it means red color like um cardinal. I
mean, it's so vague. It could mean a lot
of things. And people have a tendency to
make stuff try to fit based on Mhm.
um what they think it might be. But this
is contradictory to another prophecy
that has been circling lately and that
is the one from St.
Malake. Um this is gaining a lot of
traction in the news right now and he
supposedly predicted all the popes until
the last from the time
of
11:43 until now. to he's he said the
until the end. So there's like a a
certain number of popes that were going
to come in and Francis was the last
number of them. See now it depends on
how you interpret the document. This is
where it gets a little bit tricky. But
this guy by all intents and purposes,
you know, he lived from 1094 to 1148. He
was the legate of Ireland. say that
means he was appointed by the pope to be
more or less to Ireland that the buck
stops here.
Um and he was also credited with what's
called the prophecy of the popes which
is what we were just referring to. So
this is what all the the hype about. And
um there's two ways of looking at this.
One version is that Francis was the last
one. Mhm. Well, where does that leave
us? If they're in the middle of electing
another one, right? Then it would make
this thing not Yeah. not valid at all.
Right. Yeah.
Another version says that between the
last two popes, there is room for extra
popes. Oh, okay. That's a different
interpretation. The last one takes the
throne, so to speak, and he also takes
the name Peter the Roman.
Yeah. because Peter was the first pope.
This is kind of like bookending. Mhm.
All that. So from 11:43
until Well, it depends. But some people
are saying 2027 is when it ends. Why
2027? They they look at the sum total of
the prophecy and they they find the
midway mark. Mhm. and they calculate the
remainder of the years um based on um
midway to so from the first to the
midway and they calculate the rest of
the years from midway to the end and
they end it in 2027. Mhm. Which is
fascinating if you were to couple that
with all kinds of other belief systems
that are out there also projecting
things to happen in 2027 as well. Well,
there was also a lot of talk about 2025
which we're in right now. There's
there's a lot of talk about a lot of
dates. So there's talk about 2030 and it
seems like everybody's got a date for
the Mayans. The Mayans had that too and
nothing happened. Yep. So fascinating
that
um you know on the one hand Nostradamus
is like look this this there's going to
be a pope that's dead in 2025 and then
this prophecy of the popes by St. Malake
is supposed to say well in 2027 it's
it's all done.
I know these are these are, you know,
interesting prophecies. We could put
that in quotations.
Now, here's where it gets very
fascinating.
this prophecy of the popes that
supposedly Malakei was credited with
writing, the story goes that he he took
this document that he wrote, he took it
to the pope and then the pope looked at
it and they had it put in the Vatican
archives. Mhm.
And then it was
found Okay. or discovered, rediscovered
in 1590. Mhm.
That's almost 450 years later.
So, what is that? What does that mean?
Well, this guy that found it, Arnold
Won,
um it's believed that he was actually
working in concert with other
individuals, because until the time that
it was found, it seems like the
prophecies that were written down were
pretty accurate, like pretty
descriptive. like they they did a good
job describing who was pope until that
time. And what's believed is that in
1590 he found this and then started
continuing maybe not him but somebody
else started continuing the document.
Mhm. and he was working in concert with
them and they were trying to orchestrate
who the next pope was supposed to be
based on the prophecy instead of the one
who might be likely elected. Mhm. So
there's a lot of like political
jockeying that was done. So here I'm
going to get to what it says and then
we'll we'll get beyond that. So here's
here is what
supposedly how this all goes down
according to this document. In the final
persecution of the Holy Roman Church,
there will sit as Bishop Peter the Roman
who will pasture his sheep in many
tribulations. And when these things are
finished, the city of seven hills, we
know that to be wrong, will be
destroyed. And the dreadful judge will
judge his people. The end. The end.
Okay.
So, pretty
vague, right? Mhm.
And some people are saying this refers
to
Francis and some are saying no, no, no,
no, it's it's not Francis. Basically,
they they believed that the one before
the last one lines up pretty well with
Benedict. Mhm. By very vague
descriptions, right? But then in
between, it could be several people, it
could be one, could be two, could be a
whole bunch. And then there's there's a
last one. And this is the description of
the last one. My my question would be
the the Bible is full of verses that
show you how to test whether someone is
a legitimate prophet. And we can put a
link in the description for whoever
wants to check it out. The Bible tells
you this is what you should look for.
Yes. I would really want to put that
test on these individuals. You bet. And
then if it doesn't
fit, you know, it's not a true prophecy.
You know what's fascinating to me about
this though? There are a couple of
pieces in here
that even though they're vague, they are
almost nods to the book of Revelation.
And you wonder if somebody was looking
at Revelation and saying, "Let's see. We
can, you know, put down something that's
uh that'll work here." It's a bit of a
distraction from what the Bible is
saying. And I'll show you a couple of
verses. One of them is Revelation 17:9.
Would you mind reading that? Here is the
mind which has wisdom. The seven heads
are seven mountains on which the woman
sits. So in biblical scholarship, this
is commonly understood that the seven
heads or seven mountains is the city of
seven hills. Mhm. At least in Protestant
circles. Yeah. That this is an
identifying mark of that
um power which is identified as Babylon
in the book of Revelation, but which is
really Rome. Mhm. So it's it's it's
essentially God's finger pointing at the
Vatican. Yeah. And and we know that
physically Vatican and Rome actually
sits on seven hills. Yeah. So when that
is in this prophecy of St. Malake, it's
like okay, well that's interesting.
You're identifying Rome as part of this
piece. But the Bible does that already.
You don't have to go to St. Malachi or
anybody else. The Bible's already giving
us lots of detail. And here's another
one in Revelation 18 9 and 10. Would you
mind reading that? The kings of the
earth who committed fornication and
lived luxuriously with her will weep and
lament for her when they see the smoke
of her burning, standing at a distance
for fear of her torment, saying, "Alas,
alas, that great city Babylon, that
mighty city, for in one hour your
judgment has come." So here in the book
of revelation, we see that
Babylon is going to be destroyed. Mhm.
Just like what it was alluding to in the
prophecy of St. Malachi. And then it
basically says and then the end. Yeah.
And but this Babylon is not the original
Babylon. This is a spiritual symbol.
We're talking about essentially papal
room. Mhm. So those two pieces it seems
to you could say be right on. But but
that information already
existed from the time of John the
Revelator. Mhm. And many Bible scholars
had picked up on that through the years.
Mhm. Uh even from pre from early
times.
So also the Catholic Church comments on
this prophecy of St.
Malake. And it's it's very interesting
when you look at what they say. They
don't think it's legitimate.
And the consensus among at least their
scholars is that a 16th century forgery
um created for partisan political
reasons. And the bottom line is they
think it's a fraud. There you go. So
it's, you know, supposedly from their
people, their organization, and they're
like, "No, we don't. We don't put any
stock in this. We don't buy this. Right.
This thing is not is not legitimate. I
mean, if they were, then they would not
choose another pope, right? So, well,
yeah, and that makes sense. And so, it
brings the question though, does the
Bible tell us about the last pope? It
doesn't. Not specifically. Well, I think
it does. You think it does? I think it
does tell us about the last pope. Okay.
But not it's not going to spell it out
in the same way as Nostradamus or St.
Malaki, I believe it's it's
identifying the last pope by description
of what happens in the world. In the
world. Yes, I agree. By what the power
does. Yes. But not by saying it's this
guy or this year or this number of
popes. Yeah. But we know by the signs
that the Bible talks about that it's
identifying a power and this is what
that power will look like. And with that
power comes the association of a man.
Yep. And so where do we get that?
Actually, we get it from Daniel chapter
7 and verse 8. And there are actually
tons of clues here. So, I'm going to
read it and then we'll go through some
of the points. It says, "I was
considering the horns, and there was
another horn, a little one coming um up
among them. Before whom three of the
first horns were plucked up by the
roots, and there in this horn were eyes
like the eyes of a man, and a mouth
speaking pompous words." Now, we've
talked about this before, but prior to
verse 8 in Daniel 7, what are we seeing?
We're seeing four different beasts. And
Daniel says a beast represents a
kingdom. Okay. And what are those
beasts? Well, the first one is
representative of Babylon. It's a lion.
It has wings. Uh the second one is
representative of Meo Persia. It's a
bear leaning on its side. Has ribs out
of its mouth. And the third one is a
leopard with many heads. And it's
representative of Greece. It also has
wings. Okay. And then there's this other
power, this other beast that comes on
the scene. It's different from the
others. It's not some commonly
identifiable, right, creature, but it
has elements of all the other ones.
Yeah. And um so then in this last beast,
it's saying this is the context. It says
it has horns and it's like well this
last piece has all these horns but then
it comes to focus on one particular horn
that plucks up three others. Yeah. Mhm.
So one of the identifying marks of this
last power or you could say the the um
one of the things that this last power
will do is it comes up from among the 10
horns. These horns are essentially the
kingdoms of Western Europe. So this last
power we should expect to be found in
the region of Western Europe. Mhm. So
does Rome fit that 100% description?
Yes, it does. Okay. We also see it has
eyes like the eyes of a man. Mhm. Okay.
Eyes in the Bible denote intelligence.
Mhm. And um this is the eyes of the the
eyes of a man. And so a man at the head
of this power, this
organization that can speak for it. Mhm.
You and I were just talking before this
about some uh interesting detail about
the papacy when it comes to the United
Nations. Yes. What was that? Well, let
me read this to you. The Vatican, the
Holy Sea, holds permanent observer
status at the UN. It is not a full
voting member, but it can participate in
debates and UN meetings, submit
documents, and influence resolutions.
This unique status highlights the
Vatican's role as both a religious and
political entity on the world stage.
Yeah. Very interesting. Mhm. So, when we
look at um if we're if we're saying Rome
fits this bill, the the Vatican, the
papacy fits this bill, does it have a
man at the head of it that speaks for
it? Absolutely it does. Okay. So,
Western Europe, Rome fits the bill. Man
of the head fits the bill. Okay. We also
see here another clue. It says before
whom the first horns were plucked out by
the roots or the three, it's very
specific, three. So, there were three
kingdoms that in years past the papacy
had worked against
to usurp them. And it says they were
plucked out by the roots. These people
were, you could say, exterminated. Mhm.
They were the Ostrogoths, the Vandals,
and the Heroli. And this is a very
common known historical
uh tidbit you can look up and study and
and figure out. Yes, they worked to
remove these. There were they were
essentially they were in opposition on
some things politically, religiously.
They didn't see eye to eye. Yeah. So, it
was not in the best interest of the
Vatican for them to continue to be
around because they were opposers. He
shall be different from the first ones.
This is a clue we find in Daniel 7:24.
It would be different than the other 10
kingdoms. This is what it's talking
about contextually. Different in what
way? Well, the thing you read from the
United Nations gives us a clue. It's not
just a secular power. Mhm. It's a church
state power. It's a church state power.
It's a religious power as well. Mhm. And
so the person that's at the head doesn't
just act as head of state, they act as
head of a religion. And that's very
unique. And there are probably not many
um kingdoms that are set up that way
where the person at the top is both the
head of the church and head of the
state. Yeah. And so for example, we have
the the the King Charles as the monarch
of England. He's the head of the Church
of England.
However, he doesn't fit the rest of the
description. Like, yeah, he's Western
Europeish, you know, but has he plugged
up these three entities? And when you do
this whole study, which for those who
are interested, we have a video, we'll
put a link in the description that
fleshes all of this out very in depth.
There's so many there's there's 10
points that you can um where you can
pinpoint this power, right? All 10 have
to fit. Yeah, King Charles doesn't fit
all 10 by any means. Yeah, for sure. We
go to Daniel 7:21. We get another clue.
It says that this um power makes war
against the saints. Now, who are the
saints? It's God's people. God's people.
The Bible common it uses that term many
times to refer to God's people. It calls
them the saints. And this power makes
war against them. Mhm. Uh it says even
that it prevails against them. So in
other words, there are times where the
saints aren't they're they're being
overwhelmed, overcome by this power. Is
there a power or does Rome or the
Vatican I should say fit the description
of a power that
persecuted the saints? Yes. I mean the
estimates is what like 50 million but
that's moderate. That's that's that's
being shy about it. It's probably a lot
more Yeah. of Protestants that were
killed during the time of the
Reformation. Again, people who opposed
the system. And I think what's
interesting, what what I should say
about this, I I appreciated a way that I
heard a pastor say this once, so I'm
going to say
it. This is not about
um
condemning Catholics. No. No.
Really, if we were put things into into
perspective, this is our history
collectively in Christianity.
Because
Protestantism found um you know, it came
out of Catholicism. It was part of a
church. It was the only church that
really you could say kind of existed, at
least you know, some big official
capacity. There might have been God's
people scattered here and there um that
you could classify as the church as
well, but Protestants largely came out
of this. And so we can look back and say
this is part of our history. It's not
pretty. Mhm. Um there were things that
were done that we can look back and say,
"Yeah, we could have done a better job
as far as Christianity collectively in
times past." Mhm. Um there were some
things that were done that were not not
good, but leading the way was that
church state power to persecute the
saints. And that's why we are
so thankful and adamant about freedom of
conscience and freedom of religion to be
able to worship the way you want and not
have somebody persecuting you, right?
Because you think or believe differently
or want to carry out actions that are
that are different. Mhm. uh in the way
that you
worship. So if we go back to um Daniel
7:25, we see this it reinforced shall
persecute the saints of the most high.
So it's not just saying it once, it's
saying it multiple times. This is a
description of that power. And we know
many people lost their lives during
times like the Inquisition and Crusades
and and all kinds of all kinds of stuff.
When we go back to Anneal 7:8, there's
another clue and it says it comes up um
among them. This kingdom comes to power
by emerging
from pagan Rome. Mhm. It didn't just
come out of nowhere. It's pagan Rome is
where it comes from. Mhm. Um that's the
fourth kingdom that's that's mentioned
in Daniel 7 is is really what it's
talking about. Yeah. and fascinating um
you know if you look at the statue in
Daniel chapter 2 when it gets to the
part of Rome which is the iron it's what
what an anatomical feature it's oh it's
the the legs legs how many legs are
there two two and so we see with Rome
there are two branches there is the
pagan faith which was you know the
ruling power during the time of Jesus
that persecuted Mh. You know, Christians
and and even, you know, and then we have
the papal phase. Mhm. Which continued on
essentially right after it was I
wouldn't say it was a smooth transition,
but it was a transition from one phase
to another phase. Right. It just kind of
changed form more or less. That's
interesting. I've never thought about
that before, but it's true. Yeah.
We go back to Daniel 7:25. There's
another clue. says, "The saints shall be
given into his hand for a time, times,
and half a time." Okay. So, what does
all that mean? It means God's people
would be handed over or put under the
control of or be dominated by Yeah. this
power for this
cryptic time frame that's listed in the
Bible. Mhm. And that time is time,
times, and half a time. So when you look
at this, this is how it's calculated.
Time is equal to a year. Times is equal
to 2 years. And half a time is equal to
half a year. How do we know that? How do
we know that? Mhm. We know that in part
from other passages in the Bible. So for
example, if you look at the um
Nebuchadnezzar Mhm.
Okay. Nebuchadnezzar was
um essentially sentenced by God to act
as a beast. Mhm. For seven years. Mhm.
In the Bible, it says seven times shall
pass over you. And that's seven years.
And it was seven years. That makes
sense. So we're using that and other
passages to determine this is what a
time means. Okay, a time. So a time is a
year, times two years because it's
plural. Half a time, half a year. So we
get to three and a half years. Well,
what does that really mean? Because
we're talking about Bible prophecy.
We're not just talking about any number
of days or weeks or years or what have
you. Well, in Bible prophecy, that three
and a half years is equivalent. is
equivalent to 1260 days. It's equivalent
to 42 months. They all add up to the
same thing. And and we're
determining um this is based on a 360day
um year and it's it's calculated
um it's like reverse engineering. Mhm.
So if you know
um three and a half years is equivalent
to 1,260 days, you divide the 1260 days
by the three and a half to get the
number of days in a year. Yeah. Does
that make sense? And you can also fact
check with Revelation that speaks of the
same event where you also get to 1260
days or years. So it Revelation and
Daniel go hand in hand. Yes. So it's
essentially it's a bad calculation to
arrive at the 360 and that's how we know
that it is. So that time frame is
prophetic years because we are not
talking about a um a literal 3 and 1/2
years. We're talking about a prophetic 3
and 1/2 years. And there are passages in
the Bible that help us determine
um when there are prophetic years and
when there are, you know, literal years.
And so this power it says the saints are
given over for 1260
years
and we have clues in the Bible and other
you this is in other videos and stuff
that we make but essentially that time
frame goes from 538 to 1798. Mhm. And if
we look back in history we can say yes
this is a good fit for that church state
power that Vatican papal power because
this is the period of the dark ages.
Mhm. It reigned from 538 to 1798 until
it received a deadly a deadly wound.
Okay. So,
um this is a clue to tell us about, you
know, the last pope or the last power.
Mhm. We go back to Daniel 7:25, we find
another clue. He shall speak pompous
words against the most high. Who is the
most high? It's Jesus. It's God. Yeah.
Mhm. So this power is speaking pompous
or some translations say blasphemous
words against the most high. Um in
Revelation
13:5 the Bible says that same power
speaks great things and blasphemies.
Okay. So the Daniel 13 has some parallel
passages to Daniel chapter 7. So also
what you're saying so shall speak
pompous words or blasphemies. According
to the Bible, blasphemy is saying that
you are a god and saying you can forgive
sins, which is two different aspects of
the papacy, right? They have priests
where you have to confess your sins to a
man, which the Bible says there's only
one mediator between God and man, which
is Jesus Christ. And only Jesus can
forgive sins.
And I was I was reading the news today
and even secular news media are saying
yeah that the the pope was considered
the substitute uh for Christ on earth
that he was God and they have the their
own statements the Catholic Church has
his own statement saying the pope is God
on earth and so that applies to this as
well. Yeah. and and you can look at
articles like or documents like Vatican
2 that confirm all of this kind of
stuff. And there's I I understand that
there's a lot of controversy on how some
of those things can be interpreted. I've
looked at them. I've read them. You
know, when it seems like at the end of
the day, it's not saying anything any
different than it has in the past,
right? It may just be rewarding it,
retooling it, reframing it, but at the
end of the day, they're claiming to be
the power. And they are expecting that
everybody should return
back to them, the mother church. The
mother church. Yeah. Um I just saw a
news clip the other day of someone who
was suggesting that we all need need to
unite and go back to the Catholic
Church. Mhm. So, um this is the
prevailing
sentiment. We also learn in Daniel 7:25,
another clue is that he shall intend to
change times and law. Mhm. This passage,
this whole section that Daniel's dealing
with, um when he's talking about this
power and it and it persecutes just
saints and it's speaking blasphemous or
pompous words, this is written in a
religious power context. Mhm. And so the
laws that it intends to change if it's a
blaspheming power are laws that have to
do with God's laws. Mhm. And times that
God has set in order. Mhm. And that is
what it's referring to. It's not just
any law, any time. Right. It's
specifically religious times and
religious laws. Mhm. And if you were to
look at the Bible and say, "Well, what
what are God's laws?" like what
religious laws would still
be applicable today. Mhm.
One example would be the ten
commandments. Mhm. And and the fourth
commandment is the commandment that has
to do with time. It is it's a it's a
commandment that has to do with time and
our relationship with God. So this power
is has known has stated we can provide
links to other videos about this but it
is stated that it has the power to
change God's law and God's times. I mean
we in the video I referenced earlier um
about how that the papacy is the power
of virtue in these verses. I showed a
bunch of quotes, maybe like 10, 15
quotes that just all speak of the papacy
saying, "Yeah, we changed. We changed
Sunday to Sabbath." And in fact, if you
are a Protestant keeping Sunday, yes,
you are giving acknowledging the papacy
as the your supreme ruler. They're
saying if you're going to make the Bible
your rule of faith, if you're going to
be intellectually honest, you would be
worshiping on the Sabbath because we're
the ones claiming authority to change
the day of worship. Yeah, they admitted
themselves. We have changed it. So
that's very
fascinating. So again, Rome, the papacy,
this last power is is the one saying,
"Yeah, we have authority to do that."
And it's an identifying mark of who it
is. Mhm. If we go to
Revelation 13, we
see some other information that we can
couple with this this one. Would you
read this verse to me? Then I saw
another beast coming up out of the earth
and he had two horns like a lamb and
spoke like a dragon and he exercises all
the authority of the first beast in his
presence and causes the earth and those
who dwell in it to worship the first
beast whose deadly wound was healed. So,
when we're talking about this power
being a a power that wants to change
time and law, and you couple that with
what it says in Revelation 13,
that there
is coming an
enforcement of worship.
It's not a far stretch
to say, well, how do people
worship? Well, in a Christian context,
people worship by joining together Mhm.
on a particular day out of the week and
using that day in in dedication to God
through prayer, Bible study, the
preaching of the word,
um doing activities that would uh help
promote um goodwill, you know, to
humanity, relieve suffering, things like
that. If we're causing people to worship
Mhm. this is forced. Mhm. So it's it's
saying this power will get to the point
where it will not tolerate Mhm. you
doing thing anything differently than
what they're doing. Mhm. That's not
religious freedom. That's going back to,
you know, the way it was before where
people are persecuted, they will be
persecuted again. Yep. According to this
passage. That's right. And then we see
how it takes it a step to another step
in Revelation 16 or I mean Revelation
13:16 and 17. Do you mind reading this?
He causes all both small and great, rich
and poor, free and slave to receive a
mark on their right hand or on their
foreheads and that no one may buy or
sell except one who has the mark of or
the name of the beast or the number of
his name. All right. So, it's a
persecuting power. Mhm. It's a power
that is going to enforce worship or
force worship in a way that is
different than you may be used to, may
desire to do, than your conscience may
lead you to do. Mhm. And it's going to
enact penalties
if you don't tow the line. When you look
at history, history is a great um tool
to look forward. Mhm. When you look at
history, you can say, not only does this
power have all these marks of
identification that it fits the Vatican,
that it fits the papacy. When you look
forward in Revelation to see what is
going to happen in the end, all those
things come back.
So while it may have a deadly wound now,
that deadly wound is healing. And it a
power is laying dormant so to speak,
gaining power, gaining strength to come
back to full strength so that it can
reign and have sway in a way that it
used to. That's right. It may look a
little different and there are going to
be other entities involved. And of
course, we have other videos about that.
But to go back to our original premise,
what does the last pope look like? What
is the last pope? Who is the last pope?
The Bible doesn't tell us the name of
the individual. The Bible gives us some
clues. It talks about the number of his
name. And the Bible gives us many
descriptions of what this power will be
like and where it's from and how it
operates and and and all of that. Yep.
And so who is the last pope?
Essentially, the last pope is whoever's
sitting in the throne of the papacy at
the end of time carrying out all of
this to persecute God's people,
including the mark of the beast. Yeah.
So, that's the last pope. And the Bible
tells us everything that we need to
know. So, we don't have to go to
Nostradamus. We don't have to go to the
prophecies of St. Malachi. And what I
like about the Bible
is these are written in a way that
they're timeless. It's it's not trying
to set people up for some specific date
because God knows how humanity is. He
knows if there's some specific date,
we're procrastinators. Oh, we'll put off
our salvation. Yep. We'll put off
getting ready until well, yeah, 6 months
before, the year before, 3 months
before,
instead of being ready now, and that's
what God wants for us. He wants us to be
ready now. We should be ready to face
whatever will come. And God will give us
the strength to do that just like he did
the people that came before us. Yeah.
And so it doesn't matter what
year. Look for the signs that the Bible
has has determined. Look for the clues
that the Bible has determined in this
video and other videos to see who is the
last pope. I believe we're close. I
believe we're on the horizon. Oh yeah.
And I believe it wasn't Francis because
he's dead and a new one is on the way.
But it doesn't matter if it's that one
or another one to come behind him. It's
whoever executes this end time scenario
that is the last hope. And I think the
essence of all of this is not to be
afraid. Yeah. Not to worry like, oh wow,
I've studied this. I understand this and
I understand that we're really close.
The essence is Jesus. Absolutely.
So studying the prophecies should point
us back to Jesus. The pro the revelation
one verse one revelation of Jesus Christ
of Jesus Christ is a revealing and and
and opening up of information about
Jesus Christ. And so this should cause
us to want to come to Jesus and have a
closer relationship with him and say,
"Lord, I see I've been living my life in
a way that doesn't line up with your
will as described in the Bible and help
me to overcome my sins to be fully
surrendered to you, though the heavens
may fall." And and in Revelation, we're
seeing a stark contrast between who
Jesus is and what he's like and that
power that imitates him or masquerades
and has many of the same qualities. It's
very fascinating when you look at the
Bible, how closely Satan will take an
end time power and have some of the same
aspects that that look like Christ, but
it doesn't act like Christ. Mhm. And
that's where the proof is in the
pudding. It has to act like Christ. We
need to act like Christ in these last
days. Yep. So, yeah, that that's the
answer. It may not be the answer people
were looking for. They probably wanted
to know a name or a a date, but the
Bible doesn't give us that. I think
there's more value in what you have
shared than just us dropping a name and
saying that one. Yeah, we've been given
all the clues and we know when the time
will come. Yeah. And that's all we need.
And again, we've got more videos on
this. We've got a video on who one of
these beast powers is and how the United
States is actually involved in end time
prophecy. We got a video on who the
Antichrist is. And again, how the papacy
fulfills this kind of power that you
just described like in depth. You can
just go through go through these verses
that Keith just shared. Definitely just
study for yourself. Um, and we've got a
video on what the mark of the beast is,
which is going to be enforced by the
Antichrist power. So, worth checking out
and study your own Bible. Amen. If you
like this video, like, subscribe, and
hit the notification bell so you know
when we launch new videos. and drop a
comments below and we'll try to get back
to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]